et bonjour merci d'être en direct avec
nous alors un nouvel attentat contre les
intérêts français d'après le ministère
des affaires étrangères la france est
définitivement devenu une cible dans les
pays musulmans selon vous alors je ne le
pense pas parce que la deuxième attaque
visez plutôt les intérêts européens et
la présence en tête le fait que la
communication a été forcément concentré
sur la présence de l'ambassade français
l'été parce que le consul français c'est
parce qu'il peut céder là ils ont les
leurs en diplomatique le plus haut parmi
les présents ainsi il faut se demander
est ce que c'est les intérêts plutôt de
la france y sont visés ou plutôt les
intérêts saoudiens parce que rappelons
nous que le 20 octobre va se situer va
se dérouler le sommet extraordinaire des
pays du g20 et s'est pour la première
fois que l'arabie saoudite prend ou
encore un pays du moyen orient va
organiser ce sommet est donc la réussite
d'un sommet pareil vase défini en fait
la réussite de toute une région et non
pas uniquement celle de l'arabie
saoudite d'où la question que je suis en
train de me poser s'il allait c est ce
que les intérêts français sont usés ou
ou plutôt est ce que c'est il s'agit
uniquement en fait de faire de nuire à
la réputation de l'arabie saoudite dans
un contexte assez précis justement on a
pu voir ces dernières années que
l'arabie saoudite le royaume dans son
intégralité essaie de se donner une
image plus moderne on a vu plusieurs
déclarations de la part par exemple les
femmes ou autre en tout cas ils veulent
se présenter aujourd'hui d'une manière
plus moderne sur la scène internationale
cette dimension justement pourrait aller
en tire les volontés terroristes de
certains fondamentalistes selon vous
alors il est nécessaire de dire que
nécessaire de dire qu'il y a une volonté
de la part des autorités saoudiennes de
pouvoir effectuer des réformes les
réformes en demies sont devenues
nécessaires surtout vu laminé mille
différentes mutations économiques
sociales en arabie saoudite et donc la
vision 2030 est venu pour accompagner
cette modernisation est amorcé cette
modernisation que ça soit une hausse de
l'énergie
des droits des femmes et donc ceux là ça
dépasse de loin les simples blood com ou
bien la simple réputation dessin de la
simple réputation affichée toutefois il
ne faut pas dire qu'il ne faut pas nier
que les actes terroristes peuvent se
passer un peu n'importe où est donc
destiné par la plus unique qui est en
fait un surtout de contradiction entre
la vie de certains fondamentalistes qui
sont là qui pourrait être
qui pourrait contester mais il est
probable qu'ils ne pourraient pas passer
au delà de la simple contestation lors à
savoir passer à l'acte et donc les actes
terroristes s'inscrivent dans le cadre
des mouvements ces terroristes aux
mondiaux les à des attentats terroristes
aux mondiaux notamment celui qui s'est
déroulé il ya à peu près de trois
semaines qu'ils considèrent de trois
jours après celui de l'attentât de paris
on a vu les derniers propos d'emmanuel
macro qui ont qui ont visé justement là
l'islamisme radical des propos qui ont
été mal perçue par certains pays arabes
qui ont d'ailleurs boycotter des
produits français on pense au 14 mai
également la turquie qui est monté au
créneau en arabie saoudite s'était moins
limité il ya aujourd'hui une vraie
division au sein de l'islam l'islam qui
est produit en arabie saoudite et celui
qui est voilà qui est perçu par exemple
au qatar qui finance d'ailleurs le
terrorisme il est indéniable qu'elle
manie qu'a travers les déclarations du
président macron on vise clairement le
la mouvance des frères musulmans
il faut pas nier aussi qu'au sens du
monde à ras du monde arabo musulman il y
a une certaine concurrence pour le
leadership du monde sunnite
d'aujourd'hui entre lax saoudo émirates
aux égyptiens d'un côté et là que turco
qatarie de l'autre et ceux ci se
manifeste au travers des différentes
crises que ça soit la crise libyenne
avant la crise syrienne
l'eau s'indigne des différentes dossier
donc on peut pas nier qu'il ya une
certaine concurrence et que le fait
disons la contestation saoudienne au
visa vite on était des caricatures était
bien placé ceci a été traduit par les
propos du président tadic islamique
mondiale qui a bien dit que on condamne
plus on condamne ces caricatures mais
cela
ne mérite par intel intel en fait
contestation où une telle utilisation
d'un compte du politique il faut pas
il a dit aussi qu'il ne faut pas donner
cette grande dimension à la à la
contestation qui pourrait en fait
bénéficier politiquement certains
acteurs merci beaucoup
rassam est d'avoir réagi sur notre
antenne est je rappelle que vous êtes
fondateur de digg